to say in one sentence it's to connect
the world through books it's to take
this uh this thing we all love and
benefit from which is books and reading
and connect us uh create a that's
through a Marketplace that's through
social a lot of our users are actually
meeting other people because what's cool
about Pango books is you go into
somebody's shop and look at what they're
selling and often you can actually find
other people with your same interests
just because you know for me I look up a
lot of uh you know startup business
entrepreneurship books so it's pretty
cool when I find the people that are
selling them often we we share a lot of
interests um but that's really what it
is is to turn uh the entire world into a
[Music]
bookstore Grant Singleton welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
being with me today how are you
fantastic and thanks for having me it's
definite pleasure thank you so much for
being here Grant H I'm really excited to
talk about your journey your passions h
all the way from you know Pango books
today to the US Navy before and uh you
know so many different things for us to
touch on either on the entrepreneurial
Journey the personal Journey so tell me
a little bit about yourself now that
we've shared with the audience right
before we started this episode they
heard your bio and your background I'd
love to hear in your in your own words
how do you see your own sort of Journey
connecting the dots backwards leading up
to Pango books and then we'll dive into
what you're doing with Pingo
books yeah definitely so for me uh it's
been a crazy Journey with a lot of
different TR trajectories I was actually
a baseball player uh in high school had
no business Acumen graduated the middle
of my class so like out of 500 people I
was 250 out of
500 uh you know no real big academic
prospects uh academics wasn't something
I really ever focused on I knew I wanted
to serve my country uh so right after
high school I joined the Navy spent four
years there most of that was in Japan on
an aircraft carrier living in super
close quarters like you know 100 uh
Sailors shoved into a tiny room uh so
the biggest takeaway for me from the
military was discipline um you know
getting up early working hard to
accomplish uh your goals a lot of the
work was really really hard some of it
was fun but when I got out uh what I had
Learned was pretty much anything I could
do in the real world was easier than
what I had done in the military or what
what I was required to do in the
military so it made uh stuff like
academics engineering a lot easier and
so I immediately started pursuing an
engineering degree uh you know got a
computer engineering degree from A&M
that was not easy because I I just was
not a math background had to really have
a growth mindset uh to get through that
and then after becoming an engineer like
the World opened up to me I mean I got
so excited about the possibilities of
what I could build uh because you know
that's what's true about being a
software engineer you can build anything
uh and so while I was working at raikon
uh as a just a C++ developer in their
space Department I uh built Pango got a
passion to build a social networking
Marketplace for books um you know built
at Moonlighting and then here we are
today but that's kind of my journey up
to this
point so used books Marketplace for
books sort of reminds me the very early
days of of Bezos in Amazon where how
what's your relationship with with books
that led you to Pango
books yeah the Bezos bit is funny
because everybody says that and then
it's actually uh it's like oh your
competitors's Amazon so yeah books with
me I just fell back in love with reading
during the pandemic so everybody had
their pandemic H hobby that they picked
up and mine uh was reading and I don't
know if you've read like mindset by
Carol D about having you know fix versus
a growth mindset and that book is a
great example of the power of the power
of a book a single book has the
potential to change your life forever uh
and so that's really that part of it is
what I really grasped on to and wanted
to build something around the power of
books and that's why my mission is
really to connect people through books
so really just started with a love of
reading and the power that a book can
have in somebody's life and so still
that the the journey from a passion or a
hobby to a full-on business and a
company is not trivial tell me a little
bit about the journey that you've had in
the I guess the initiation process of of
building Pango books or coming up with
the idea for Pango books yeah so it
started really off testing the waters uh
so you know I had this idea basically to
build Poshmark for books uh or Mar for
books or eBay for book for Just Books
whatever Marketplace you want to think
of as an analogy uh I wanted to have a
social bent um but really I didn't think
it would take off and become anything
big uh so I started off really
experimental I thought this is something
you know I built the MVP Moonlighting in
three months so in three months I had
something on the App Store a low initial
investment totally bootstrapped didn't
spend any money uh and then immediately
it got Traction in like the Gin Z
culture like on book talk and
bookstagram uh and it was that initial
traction that I you know I was thinking
it was going to be mainly textbooks and
you know maybe homeschool moms
exchanging kind dollar books I didn't
think it was going to be people selling
like Harry Potter and uh you know young
adult fantasy fiction just your normal
everyday romance novels and when I found
that that's what people were actually
using it for and these really book
obsessed people um you know myself being
one of them found a home on Pango books
that's when it got really serious and I
looked to you know take it to the next
level by raising money so really just
started out experimental and that's kind
of been the story of my life uh up until
that point there just a lot of
experiments and finding the spaghetti
that's stock and uh you know put it on a
plate and that's really what this
was and so the you know the the model
that you went with Pingo books so you
took that love for books and a vision of
wanting to to have others continue to
enjoy that gift what what what what did
you realize about the current state of
the market or the different consumer
Behavior trends that led to the specific
model of Pingo books and and maybe we'll
start with tell me a little bit about
what is the model of Pingo books which
is quite an interesting
model yeah I'll start with a model it's
a Marketplace model uh so we are a
platform we don't have any inventory we
don't physically sell books unless we're
literally selling them out of our shop
um you know we have a take rate we take
a percentage of every sale just like an
eBay barari Poshmark that's the business
model um as far as like what I saw in
the market I saw an underserved
Community I mean if you see there's like
five to 10 fashion apps like like
Poshmark deop uh there's a lot of
different very successful even
unicorn uh businesses in a lot of these
different Niche uh Industries for
Marketplace but there was nothing for
books and so I started looking into why
there's a lot of book sellers but
there's no dedicated Marketplace for
books Beyond Amazon and that's still
mainly not you know peer-to-peer so it
was you know I saw that there was a
community of Book Lovers who didn't
really have amazing resources to buy and
sell with each other uh the average
American has 115 books on their
bookshelf and yeah if you think about
physical books with no real good way
unless you become an Amazon seller or
you just want to donate them and get rid
of them and that's what a lot of people
do they just donate a giant box of books
and they don't get any money nobody
thinks about monetizing their their
bookshelf uh and so that's really the
what I found uh what we found kind of
like how you know Uber discovered
everybody's got a car they don't use it
all the time and they can use their car
to make extra cash Well everybody's got
a ton of books but they're not utilizing
them um you know in the in the
marketplace that's that's kind of what
was discovered and then what we leaned
into but it hasn't been without its
share of difficulties I mean we do have
major competitors namely uh you know
Amazon being the big one so we don't try
to go head-to-head with them we try to
just over serve in the areas that uh we
do well in was it smooth sailing from
the get-go what what was the journey
like of discovering sort of are
fine-tuning your
Marketplace yeah so at the beginning
obviously you know we had to start the
cold start solve the cold start problem
uh where you know we were obviously
marketing the app um but there's
practically no books on it at all um
besides the ones we had listed so that
was the beginning was really Rocky I
mean we actually went two weeks
literally zero sales we were on the App
Store uh Google Play and iOS and nobody
bought anything in two weeks uh people
would come on and list and kind of look
around and see that nobody was there so
it was really hard at the beginning and
just took a lot of um you know smart
marketing to get to get inventory and
they just holding on you know a lot of
it was just not giving up early on
because uh I knew eventually Whenever
there was enough liquidity on the
platform that it would start to grow
which is what has happened we have had
over a million books get listed on the
app there's like 800 over 800,000 active
listings right now you know we started
with practically zero and that was the
hard part getting that flywheel turning
incredibly difficult and it just felt
like I was pushing a boulder up the hill
uh and you know obviously hiring an
amazing team uh you know getting
liquidity getting sellers to Market
their own shops and it all starts
feeling like you know the the flywheel
starts moving faster you know organic
growth becomes a real dominant player uh
so all these exciting things start
happening but definitely at the
beginning it was it just felt like I was
pushing on a brick wall and that was
never going to give away but it finally
did yeah no that that's really really
really cool and briefly you know your
time in the in the US Navy how how do
you find that it made that it I guess
changed the way that you're an
entrepreneur today you know for for
different s for starters it makes me a
really grateful
entrepreneur uh so you
know a lot of times this is you know a
plug for our uh for men and women who
serve in the military it's hard work
that's not you know paid off in my first
year uh in the Navy I was actually
cleaning elevator shafts and by by
cleaning I was actually busting rust and
repainting so they have these weapons
elevators that go up and down seven
decks in the carrier with no air
conditioning uh and the basically on the
equator and so it's incredibly hot and
you have a needle gun and you're just
busting rust off and then repainting and
so you you know and and you know you do
entire half day shifts so like it's not
a normal eight hour hour day so after
that uh and then a lot of it you know
you you know sometimes you know lower
ranked you know individuals are
mistreated by the upper ranks and you
can't quit your job there's often
nothing nothing you could do about it if
you're in a bad situation a lot of the
time so they go through a lot uh you
know my my hats off to anybody who
served in the military but coming out of
that just gratitude it's like I I I get
to Define my schedule I get to Define my
life I get to use uh the skills and the
discipline I learned there
but nothing will ever compare to the
difficulty of that and so you know like
I pulled several all nighter just to get
the MVP out for this but that was just
pure joy after uh doing it in the
military so I think the military set a
high standard in my life uh and applying
that to entrepreneurship you have to
have to have that um you know to be a
successful entrepreneur and so that's
just in incredible gratitude I would I
would say
dominates that's really really cool tell
me about the vision of Pingo book so now
as the
entrepreneur now as you're thinking
about growing the business and and
scaling it I'd love to start with
understanding taking the values and the
mission that you shared with me earlier
about why you started this and what
Pango books represents if you had to
outline the vision of Pango books in
this world what what vision is painted
there yeah definitely I mean to say in
one sentence it's to connect the world
through
books it's to take this uh this thing we
all love and benefit from which is books
and reading and connect us uh create a
that's through a Marketplace that's
through social a lot of our users are
actually meeting other people what's
cool about Pango books is you go on to
somebody's shop and look at what they're
selling and often you can actually find
other people with your same interests
just because you know for me I look up a
lot of uh you know startup business
entrepreneurship books so it's pretty
cool when I find the people that are
selling them often we we share a lot of
interests um but that's really what it
is is to turn uh the entire world into a
bookstore I mean that's really what
we're doing in the US is you know rather
than walking into a bookstore or just
buying it on Amazon uh we're saying hey
there's books in everybody's house uh
and everybody's house is technically a
bookshelf or a bookstore and turning the
entire United States uh and then
obviously the world when we go
International um you know to Canada in
the UK but that's that's really what it
is to create a place where people who
love to read it's just a lot of people
uh you know have a place to kind of call
home where uh they can sell get a little
cash to buy more books there's a lot of
people that do that you're looking to
buy a new book you just sell something
off yourself and you can get something
else for no cost um you know it's
definitely you know been exciting to see
that but that's 100% our mission
phenomenal now the logistically speaking
from an operations perspective how is it
working yeah so we we handle all the
logistics so and that's one of the
things that we pride ourselves in is
making it incredibly easy for sellers so
you actually you know you download the
app and within 30 seconds of downloading
the app you can have a listing on the
store you just take a picture and then
yeah you we have a barcode scanner so
you flip it over scan the barcode and
it'll fill out the form for you you set
your price uh you list it it's in the
store you can forget about it list as
many many as you want uh we have sellers
with three to 5,000 listings and that's
individual listings just because we made
it so easy to do it's just you know
point and click point and click and
we're hoping to make it even easier uh
to list in bulk um and then when the
book actually sells uh the app will just
notify you and send you a shipping label
and then what I do uh is I actually just
drop off my books that I sell in my
mailbox and put the flag up because it's
USPS Media Mail uh so I don't you don't
even have to leave the house unless you
this giant box of books somebody ordered
like 20 books R you but if you just sell
one book drop it in a mailer uh so it's
just incredibly easy the shipping you
know I think the shipping process has
made it worth it because that's you know
for a lot of people it's also a hobby
you know they're not looking to make a
lot of money uh they're just looking to
connect with other readers and kind of
sell what they're not reading anymore um
and you know they may make two three
dollars on a single book uh but it's
worth it if all they have to do is drop
it in their mailbox and so making that
selling process incredibly easy was an
absolute must and it's allowed us to get
a ton of casual inventory uh that we
otherwise you know would not have would
not have
gotten no I imagine you know I was
immediately thinking that one of the
interesting challenges here would be
from a consumer Behavior perspective how
do you get people to actually you know
follow through with the shipping speeds
or the logistic and I'm thinking by
myself I still have a package in the
mailbox I need to get for myself for for
the last month and I haven't done it I
was thinking like wow if somebody buys a
book from me I hope I'm not going to
delay or procrastinate sending it to
them how how you but I it sounds like
this wasn't really a big issue for you
no it was that that's hard it's hard
because basically you're you're taking
thousands of people and they're being
you basically because you know they're
the fulfillers of inventory and it's
definitely a Marketplace challenge um
but you know a lot of what we do like uh
heavy on reviews and ratings right we
have we display the sellers average ship
time on their like on their account so
when you buy from somebody you get an
idea of of how fast they normally ship
uh and so you can you can go with an
amazing seller that you know is going to
ship it in one day and we give that
power to the buyers that visibility to
the buyers uh but then you know
conversely we also want you know users
with no reviews to get sales uh as well
so you know we we do a little bit of our
own monitoring I mean we have a system
that you know Flags orders after 20 days
if they haven't been shipped and so we
try to do a good job of cleaning up
sellers that have goes to the platform
and still have inventory on there and
that's what we do behind the scenes um
and but honestly like our sellers once
they sell a few books and get into the
groove because like you said you'd be
worried you know you're not going to
ship it and that usually happens for the
first or second but then you just get
into a Groove and a routine you got your
packing materials you got your tape uh
and you know to drop it off at the at
the mailbox rather than drive to USPS
and it starts you know picking up a
healthy clip so it's really just
investing in our sellers over investing
in our sellers um having open lines of
communication we have a great customer
service uh chat system where people can
get a hold of us really easily and so
yeah over investing in our sellers
because they're the ones that uh make
make it possible they're the ones that
have all the inventory but yeah it's a
lot of a lot of uh empathy uh towards
users you know and I think and also
having like really forgiving policies
especially for buyers because you want
buyers because it's this the biggest
Dynamic really is you want buyers to
feel confident to make a purchase and
you want sellers to feel taken care of
and sometimes those are at odds because
you want to give a buyer a refund if a
seller is not you know shipping but then
you want the seller to feel like you're
not going behind their back and you want
them to feel taken care of and so you
know we develop we developed a really
open policy see and we can do this
because of the low price of books where
if somebody's not happy with a book we
often refund it out of our own uh you
know out of our own we pay for it
ourselves uh rather than creating a
dispute with the seller and having the
seller not get paid uh and the only the
only time we don't do that is if a
seller has a really bad track record but
if a seller has a good track record and
a buyer wants a refund we will typically
fund the refund ourselves uh and doing
things like that has just really allowed
us to build trust and I think like
especially in a new e-commerce company
trust is integral to success and so
building Trust on both sides of the
marketplace has been super important and
not easy uh but yeah what do you enjoy
most about this journey so far
definitely number one is watching people
use and get value out of something that
we're building so we have a very small
team uh everyone contributes everyone on
our team contributes at a high level uh
but watching thousands of Book Lovers
every day just get value out of this uh
you know making money finding new
listings I love watching people use
something that I had a part in and
that's I know especially as a developer
because I'm I'm really a developer
engineer first CEO second at least
that's that's how I feel about myself um
and you know every developer engineer
just wants to know that what they built
was useful and that someone got to use
it so that's the most exciting part uh
for sure and then watching the rest of
my team get to see that as well uh is
incredibly
rewarding incredible Grant thank you so
much for coming H for these 20 minutes I
really appreciate it best of luck with
Bango books I love the mission and the
vision and the personal entrepreneurial
story which sounds uh so healthy and uh
and authentic so thank you very very
much for joining me and best of luck I
look forward to continue Shing from the
side thanks Michael I really appreciate
being on appreciate you thank you